après trois jours de travaux la
conférence sur la sécurité à munich
s'est achevée en début d'après midi
l'événement a réuni 500 leaders mondiaux
de la défense de la diplomatie et du
monde du renseignement
trois jours pour réfléchir sur la
question de la perte d'influencé
progressive de l'occident face au reste
du monde alors qu'en retenir résumé avec
notre envoyé spécial bassem chab après
trois jours d'intenses cette discussion
qui avait pour thème l'affaiblissement
de l'occident ainsi s'achève la 56e
édition de la conférence munich sur la
sécurité
l'occasion pour 500 leaders du monde
politique de la défense ou encore de la
sécurité de se retrouver et d'évoquer
les problématiques qui font l'actualité
internationale emmanuel macron étaient
présents à cette conférence
il est revenu sur son impatience face à
l'allemagne et invite son voisin à
s'impliquer davantage aux affaires
européennes il a invité également ses
voisins à travailler plus à injecter
plus d'argent dans l'économie européenne
pour pallier un retard notamment face
aux états unis et face à la chine
il a dit qu'il fallait réinventer les
relations entre pays partenaires
et puis il ya eu un mot sur la russie en
disant que la russie est un partenaire
qui ne fallait pas négliger la porte est
ouverte pour l'avenir poutine il a quand
même parlé d'une politique de
déstabilisation menées par l'ue a réussi
par le fait par le biais pardon
d'acteurs publics et d'acteurs privés
sergueï lavrov le ministre affaires
étrangères russes étaient également sur
place il a parlé d'une barbarisation des
relations internationales a déclaré que
la russie était prête à travailler et à
coopérer sur l'agenda international mais
qu'il fallait arrêter de parler de la
menace
eurus d'autres pays étaient présents
notamment les états unis qui étaient
venus en masse nancy pelosi
mike pompéo le secrétaire d'état à la
défense me énergie ou encore pas mal de
parlementaires étaient là ils sont venus
défendre la politique de donald trump
notamment concernant la 5g invitant
leurs partenaires européens à appuyer
leurs politiques pour interdire la 5g de
huawei et sont revenus sur ce qu'on leur
reproche à savoir le repli des états
unis ma compo a répondu au mit au
président allemand pardon qui
reprochaient les états unis de se
replier
hilare a également annoncé que les
etats-unis étaient prêts à collaborer à
travailler davantage avec l'europe et
puis cette troisième journée a été
consacrée à la libye nos conférences de
presse a été organisée conjointement par
l'émissaire de la libye l'émissaire de
l'onu pardon pour la libye et puis avec
le ministre des affaires étrangères
allemand ils ont parlé d'un travail
conjointe entre partenaires occidentaux
pour essayer de trouver une sortie de
crise au conflit libyen
jean yves le drian le ministre des
affaires étrangères est également sur
place il est revenu sur cette question
libyenne a déclaré que les partenaires
européens ne devaient pas rester témoins
de cette scène et libyenne mais devait
participer davantage voilà comment c'est
fini cette troisième journée de cette
56e conférence de munich
une conférence qui a été clôturée par
son président monsieur sy singer qui
s'est félicité des travaux réalisés
pendant ces trois jours et espère que
les pays participants tireront les
conclusions positives de ces rencontres
pour améliorer des relations
internationales